Glamis first ever virtual best of all
and we're about to be joined by our
first ever virtual headliner
[Music]
okay I might can hear me I can hear you
how you
I might actually know what I'm more than
all right
I'm very good you kicked off this
amazing set with my new summer pop there
is power yeah you know what I had no
clue
you know what the reaction was gonna be
this song I just so wanted to release it
because you know it was really important
to me and I knew that my fans had
appreciate it I've got some amazing
incredible vocal fans I'm sure they're
watching now hey guys and I just knew
they'd appreciate it I knew they'd
appreciate me bringing out a song that I
was really passionate about as well yeah
because why is this song and the message
of it so important to you this idea of
power when I wrote this song I must have
been in a bit of a sassy nude and so I
think this song is kind of like
embracing what is and embracing the fact
that there is this little hint of
narcissism now like a sprinkling of it
because of social media and because now
our thing is to is to put on a show and
like you know build this kind of
perception of us and literally some
relationships and beginnings of interest
being dictated by things like social
media and the digital age I think that's
what I was thinking about when I when I
wrote power and it's like I think
sometimes in a relationship a person is
not in it for the the substance but you
know the real thing but in it for some
kind of power some kind of power trip
this is the from your next album which
is nuts because this album has been a
really long time in the making for you
what does and we talked about this a bit
but I think like speaking to you before
this album is really sums up a new stage
in your life doesn't it yeah well kind
of an old stage in my life but one that
I feel like is something I have to carry
with me forever regardless of my
relationship status which is that
you can find this really amazing new
world in being in realizing that you are
enough without someone else it can be
quite a tricky game to get into when you
you have to rely on someone else for
your own happiness and fulfillment and
so that's honestly what most of the
album's about it's about finding these
new heights of Independence and I
suppose you could say you know there's a
feminist aspect to it although it's more
about like as a human being having this
yeah having your own kind of power and
realizing that you can have people that
around you that support your happiness
but but ultimately you need to be your
own happiness because when we were
talking before you've been on a real
confidence roller coaster haven't you
yeah and I said to you in the interview
I think the you 10 years ago would
actually come up to you now and give you
the biggest hug and be like I'm so proud
of you what a bit of some turning points
in that for you well in my cell the
screen yeah I think when tour ended I
was suddenly hit very hard in the face
with reality and what real life was
which I felt like I didn't really have
until I came home I saw my friends and
my family and I just got into into what
I thought was actual living as opposed
to just temporariness of hotel rooms and
touring and playing on stage every night
and having that massive high and then
coming off stage and being you know
lonely and and yeah so that that kind of
crazy rollercoaster so I think it took
it took me getting off to having a break
I didn't release music for a little bit
and I yeah I just had to be human being
again and and then obviously I met my
husband and yeah that was the biggest
learning curve of them all because I
didn't think I was ever gonna you know
get married so there you go experience
to go from being a newlywed to them
being like pal
it's definitely shown that we can just
coexist really well and it's fun and
sometimes we want to
in space sometimes we just want to be
completely you know locked to each other
and it's just it's shown there
yeah it's shown like a variety of
different you know situations of
sometimes we want to be around each
other sometimes you know we want our own
space but I've always been like I've
always been like that so yeah and we
actually haven't argued or had any kind
of clashes so it's pretty cool yeah I
mean baby not many people can say that I
know he does tell me to stop singing I'm
obsessed with when I do be seen Kohl's
is the background everyone's done what
me through this through the keyhole
moment we've got going on here where are
we your house
okay so we're literally in my little
kind of studio setup area and so there's
some musical things
aka pianos and keyboard and then we've
got some art some art room petals in the
background they're kind of like
storyboards but they're they're kind of
weird but they definitely you know
thought-provoking and make you give you
some inspiration so yeah and that's kind
of it I mean that's not I don't think
there's anything else going on the
background yeah and then just me what
you are doing to get yourself through
lockdown
what are you doing any garden to get
yourself or oh gosh I am admittedly I'm
baking a lot I've suddenly become like a
chef like everyone else on Instagram I'm
making a lot of cakes I find it so
therapeutic to make cakes and then I
also I've been I think the most useful
thing I've done is have timed sessions
of things so that when I wake in the
morning I'm like oh I want to I want to
go for but I also want to read a book
but I also want to watch that that film
or finish that series so I make sure
that I do an hour of each where it
sounds really nerdy but it does work
because it means that you know that
you've accomplished a few things in the
day
you know I have to get inspiration I
have to read books I have to read poems
I have to anything that sort of triggers
something in my head to enable me to
write some music so that's what I do
personally but I think it's good to stay
active I think that's very crucial what
do you think is the thing you're gonna
take away from this lockdown experience
once it's over it's definitely given me
an indication of how we operate as
humans for example when it first started
I feel like people were kind of
panicking we know rightfully so because
you know we didn't really have any clear
guidance we don't really know what was
going on so we would panic buying and
all the things that you would do to
survive an instinct but then all you
know when that settled down and when you
know everyone kind of came to their
senses I think everyone really came
together and have helped each other
certainly where I live people have
really gone out of their way to help
other people and help more vulnerable
people and help me NHS and and you know
give that support and so it's just some
shown just how we work and how we
navigate things and how we react to
things people have been like working
really well together you know being a
team and and just getting on with it and
understanding that you know desperate
times you have to you know sort of think
outside the box and go a little bit
further than just what you usually do
and so actually generally it's to me
it's been a been a kind of positive
experience I think you've also learned a
lot about your own power through
exercise haven't you well I get a lot of
messages from people saying how do you
say motivate how do you do it how do you
keep training on tour and whatever but
you know what trust me I find it as hard
as the next person to get up in the
morning and want to go to the gym or go
out for a run I I think I said the seal
so I literally have to force myself I
just like pickup away or I go down and
just do like one like press up or
something or even a stretch even just a
stretch or a walk and I just you know
already helps having an activity having
a watcher tells me how much activity
that to me really has really helped
I'm just like a little side note I truly
believe that keeping fit and keeps you
keeps you in a check I think oh my god
for sure and I also think a bit
positivity goes where you're spread
spreading the positivity today with that
good I can't thank you enough for being
on the car path for sharing your story
with me having me so thank you and Dan
have always supported me since the very
beginning so thank you very much